was it right
what i did
ask me again in 10 years
try not to worry ollie i've been
worrying about john for years
he always comes back
soon after
the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over
till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones anna
song of ice and fire update video well
my friends it looks like we now have one
hell of an update from the man himself
mr george rr martin now for those of you
who may not know there was a recent
article written by james hibbard stating
hbo was in the works on a game of
thrones sequel show about jon snow
in that new article it also said hbo was
working directly with kid harrington on
the show basically if this new series is
ever given the green light by hbo we
would see what jon snow was up to after
the events of game of thrones season 8
finale now as far as anyone knew this
would be the first show hbo is making
that is set after the events in the main
show
well earlier this morning this
information was basically confirmed by
emilia clarke who said kit harrington
had told her about this jon snow show
himself
she also said that he had been working
on this jon snow series from the ground
up this was all very interesting
information that definitely had me and a
lot of other fans thinking about whether
or not this was actually happening
well we can now say for a fact that hbo
and kit harrington are making a new
series about jon snow we now have our
confirmation from george rr martin not
only did he reveal all of this
information was real but he also
revealed a hell of a lot more
information that i think a lot of you
will find as interesting as i did let's
have a look at his not a blog website so
you can see exactly what he said strap
in folks because he had a lot to say i
don't really have a spare moment today
if i'm being honest but i am making one
since the news has been broken about the
jon snow development yes there is a jon
snow show in development the hollywood
reporter story was largely correct and i
would expect no less from james hibbard
i have dealt with a lot of reporters
over the years and hibbard is one of the
very best an actual journalist who does
all the things journalists should do
getting the facts right talking to
sources respecting requests for
background only and off the record that
most of the clickbait sites never bother
with as of right now our working title
for the show is snow
there are four live-action successor
shows in development at hbo word got out
about three of them a while ago i think
some of these were officially announced
these things always seem to leak there
are so many involved like writers agents
and everyone has assistants and there's
always the guy who runs the xerox
machine and reporters have sources so
snow has been in development almost as
long as the other three but for whatever
reason it was never announced and it
never leaked until now
but yes it is real this was not an
official announcement from hbo so it
seems there was another leak i did a
long interview with james ebert last
week for the big house of the dragon
story for the hollywood reporter at the
end of the interview he asked a few
questions about the successor shows
james hibbard wanted to know if one of
them was a sequel i answered no comment
then he asked is there a member of the
original show that is involved and i
again answered no comment and that was
all but he found someone more
forthcoming than me
who i don't know and i suspect i never
will a good journalist never reveals his
sources
there's not much more i can say right
now not until hbo gives me a green light
it seems as though amelia clark has
already mentioned that snow was kit's
idea in a recent interview so that is
already out yes it was kit harrington
who brought the idea to us i cannot tell
you the names of the writers and
showrunners since that has not been
cleared for the release yet however kit
did bring them in too his own team and
they are terrific
various rumors are floating around about
my involvement or lack of the same i am
involved just as i am with the hedge
knight the sea snake and ten thousand
ships and all the animated shows kit's
team has visited me here at my home in
santa fe and worked with me and my own
team of brilliant talented writers and
consultants to hammer out the show all
four of these successor shows are still
in the script stage outline and
treatments have been written and
approved scripts have been written notes
have been given second and third drafts
have been written as well
so far that's all that is the way tv
works don't forget nothing has been
greenlit yet and there is no guarantee
when or if it will be or any of these
shows the likelihood of all four shows
getting on the air well i'd love it but
that's not the way it works usually
there's all sorts of reasons pilots
never get brought up the series all
sorts of reasons scripts never get shot
all sorts of reasons great treatments
never get sent to script that's the way
the business works this is a new day
though so here is hoping one or two or
three or all four of the game of thrones
successor shows make it on the air
that's all i can say about snow just now
if hbo says i can say more then i will
well there you have it folks the jon
snow series has now been confirmed by
george rr martin himself and i must say
all of this new information he shared is
insane i was not expecting all of this
whatsoever the fact that george rr
martin likes this idea and is also
working on the show says a lot he
obviously isn't bothered by the fact
that hbo wants to show what is happening
with john even after george rr martin's
ending i'm assuming they must have some
really great ideas in mind for where jon
snow could go in the future this also
makes me think kid harrington was not
happy with how jon snow's story ended i
feel like he has some void he wants to
fill by showing what jon snow will
really do after daenerys is dead and
brain stark is now the new king
as i've said in other videos there are
all kinds of different things they could
have this character do i won't get into
all of that here again
most of you already know some of my
ideas if you saw my version of game of
thrones season 9.
now since i've already made one video
and released it earlier today i don't
want to spend too much more time on this
one i just had to fill you in on the new
details because this story is getting
more and more exciting each day
the fact that they have also been
working on this show since some of the
other successor shows were brought
george's way is interesting as well they
are most likely much further along in
the developmental stages on this show
than we originally thought i don't know
about all of you but i'm getting very
excited for the show i hope hbo gives
this the green light i want to see this
more than i do house of the dragon as
i'm sure some of you already know i've
always been a bigger fan of house stark
than i was of house targaryen
not only that but i've always wanted a
show about the north and its mysteries
although i don't know what this show
will actually be about i guess we will
just have to wait and see what happens
either way i'm very excited and ready
for more
let me know how all of you feel about
this information leave your thoughts
down below
as always i want to thank everyone for
watching another video i hope you all
have a great day i'll see you soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
you